من بين براثن الموت تولد الحياه في زلزال
سوريا قصه لعمليه انقاذ طفله اشبه بمعجزه
عثر عليها عمال الانقاذ وهي لا تزال
مرتبطه بالحبل السري لامها التي لقيت
حتفها تحت الانقاض
داخل حاضنه في مستشفى عفرين وضعت المولوده
الجديده
مع كدمات عديده ومع ساحجات كامل جسمها
البنت وجدتها كمان بازيه برد البنت شديد
تمتد فئه الطفله كارثيوم اعطائها سكر
ووضع المستقر
الطفله هي الناجيه الوحيده من اسرتها
المباشره بينما لقي الباقون حتفهم في منزل
العائله ببلده جندريس فيري في حلب الشمالي
وضعت جثث الضحايا على ارضيه منزل قريب
المجاور قبل جنازه جماعيه يوم الثلاثاء
منزل الاسره كان واحدا من بين خمسين منزلا
دمرها الزلزال في بلده جندريس معظم السكان
ناجحون من دير الزور
عندما تفكر فيما يحدث في سوريا الان ازمه
انسانيه طويله الامد وازمه اقتصاديه كبيره
وتفشي وباء الكوليرا والان هذه الازمه
الاضافيه في سياق شتاء قاس ونقص كبير في
الوقود يكاد يكون الوضع اشبه بالعاصفه
الكاسحه وتوالي كل هذه الازمات يؤدي الى
معاناه هائله
[موسيقى]
الشوارع شمالي غربيه سوريا يبكي الصغار
والكبار والمباني سويت بالارض المستشفيات
المحليه مليئه بالجثث
الزلزال كان شديدا وبقوه تفق 20 مليار
كيلوغرام من المتفجرات بحسب خبراء لكن بين
ركام الدمار فتعالى صيحات النجاح
لم يستسلم للطفل هارون لجدار اسمنتي على
يمينه
وركام على يساره وقاوم حتى النجع
[تصفيق]
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله اما الطفله نور
فكان وجهها مغطى بالغبار ودفن جسدها تحت
الانقاذ حتى صدرها لكنها لم تصب بجروح
بالغه حفر احد المنقذين في الانقاض بيديه
حتى تمكن مع عدد قليل من رفاقه من حمل
الطفله
لتعانق الحياه الله اكبر ما شاء الله مشهد
المالوف بشكل مؤلم للعديد من العائلات
السوريه وعمال الانقاذ المنهكين من سنوات
قاتمه من القصف والنزوح